How do we use pre-processing. We know that we can find structures like these in our graph.
And here can be other connections possibly--it don't have to be, but we'll ignore those for now.
Now, if we look at this structure from a brute force perspective, there are eight different possibilities
for assigning or not assigning these vertices here into a vertex cover.
The eight possibilities are as follows: either we can take no vertex at all into the vertex cover
and you already know that this going to cause a problem and we could take all of them
into the vertex cover, and then then the six more combinations.
A brute force search tree would look at eight possible assignments.
Out of these eight assignments, if you were to design a search tree that directly
branches into these cases here, there's only five cases that would even make sense.
Please check which of these cases would make sense for a search tree.